no
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 más cerca
la farmacéutica pfiezer anunció que su
solución tuvo más de un 90 de
efectividad según el ensayo inicial
en que es un gran día para la ciencia es
un gran día para la humanidad
los expertos dieron el visto bueno a los
primeros datos se estima que este año se
pueden distribuir unas 50 millones de
dosis mientras que se espera que en 2021
se produzcan hasta 1300 millones una
carrera por la vacuna donde rusia afirma
haber conseguido un 92 por ciento de
efectividad
la ciencia y la tecnología no paran en
eeuu se produjo un viaje histórico
versión hiper loop completo su primer
trayecto de pasajeros en un sistema de
cápsulas de levitación de alta velocidad
se espera que la compañía pueda empezar
a operar en 2030 y podrá irse de
washington a nueva york en media hora
[Música]
ya sin dar arden está marcando el camino
en la política mundial desde su posición
de primera ministra de nueva zelanda en
el juramento de su nuevo gabinete hay
ocho mujeres cinco indígenas maoríes y
tres personas lgtb y ellos representan
colectivamente una variedad de
perspectivas diferentes representan un
gran talento una enorme experiencia y
como es de esperar en cualquier crisis
como neozelandeses tienen un gran
compromiso de servir a este país el
gobierno es el resultado de la mayor
victoria de los laboristas en los
últimos 50 años en nueva zelanda
[Música]
la inclusión va de oceanía hasta américa
latina' en paraguay kimberly ayala se
convirtió en la primera abogada
transexual del país después de 5 años de
negativas judiciales un mensaje de
esperanza un mensaje de luz para decirle
a la población de que si realmente se
puede uno pueden estudiar y ejercer lo
que lo que quiere ser
la abogada estuvo acompañada por la
coordinadora de derechos humanos de
paraguay y por amnistía internacional
ayala agradeció la visibilidad y presión
mediática en un juramento que abre el
camino a muchas otras personas
de los derechos trans a la inclusión de
la diversidad mariana ávila recibió el
premio quincy jones excepción advocacy
2020 por sus logros como modelo y por
haberse convertido en un ejemplo a
seguir un negocio muy triste de caer al
cielo porque me siento muy feliz creo
que soy y que sea vecino marian se
convirtió en 2018 en la primera modelo
española con síndrome de down en
desfilar en las pasarelas de la fashion
week de nueva york
[Música]
cine en femenino en túnez una forma de
empoderar a mujeres a través del séptimo
arte el proyecto forma tunecinas tanto
delante como detrás de cámaras suelen
ser jóvenes de pocos recursos y sin
ninguna experiencia ahora están rodando
la película me idea el la
historia de una tunecina que regresa a
su país para planear su propia muerte
tras ser diagnosticada con una
enfermedad terminal
[Música]